i don't i don't know how you can like i
did a script recently for the first time
and i hated it yeah i hated it
you get used to it i hated it at first
too i just i love just being a crackhead
just saying
[ __ ] just saying [ __ ] and then we'll
like we'll piece it together we'll
figure it out i mean
i'm like completely opposite i i need i
love i love making a script
like i was like kids like it's weird
because i was that kid who was just
sitting in school
and i'd just be sitting in silence and i
just like laugh at myself i'd just be
like
people thought people thought
people thought i was like [ __ ] crazy
like i would i would
yeah but like it was because i just had
all these like funny ideas and funny
jokes that
i couldn't like 13 year olds like genius
like i can't
comical mastermind there's no way i can
explain this funny thought or funny joke
i have in my head but like as soon as i
started making youtube videos i'm like
that's that's a funny thing let's let's
let's make this into a funny meme and
like i can actually visualize all the
crazy [ __ ] going on in my head
i'm not crazy i swear to god out of
context it sounds slightly autistic
it's just a little water sounds kind of
rain man yeah it is a little rain man
little god will hunting comedy
yeah i don't know though because i i
started with doing absolutely zero
scripts i would maybe jot down like
bullet points yeah but i found myself
finding
just just running into that situation
where i would just be like uh
uh like way too much in between while i
was trying to think of something so in
the end
a video where i'm trying to convince you
that you should think about an anime in
this certain way
just ended up being this like crackhead
ramble that just
was not convincing whatsoever so i was
like okay i think i got to start
organizing my [ __ ] so i just i was just
laughing too
i had the exact moment i was just
laughing to myself because i thought of
a [ __ ] goddamn
anime zone i am i am so sorry it just
happened live on screen
i'm just like god [ __ ] damn it can we
get a repeat of that as at the moment
because i wasn't i was like i wasn't
laughing at what you were saying i just
thought of a funny joke yeah
you're not funny i'm sorry i i was
derailing
what were we talking about joey i was i
was totally intently
listening to in the moment i like don't
find things funny if i think about them
too much
yeah yeah unless i do a really good joke
then the next day sometimes you
have that joke where you just like you
you just like the more you think about
it that just the funnier it gets oh yeah
no i have those jokes but it doesn't
come to the point where i'm just sitting
there laughing like
i don't think i don't think i'm funny
enough to to make those kind of jokes
i'm like damn i'm funny
damn i'm good you know i know i don't
think like sometimes
i i'm i don't think like i'm funny
enough to like think of my feet a lot of
the times but yeah
no i'm not talking about all i do i i
can't
like like if i think about a joke too
much i hate it i'm like i'm that type of
guy who's just like spends 30 minutes
and it's 30 minutes in the shower slam
dunking people
like witch remarks that i didn't make
when at the exact time
you don't know this bro but i totally
[ __ ] just destroyed you in my head
and then everyone clapped and cheered
like it's like the ending of evangelions
like translation often do you need to do
this
you think about this in the shower are
you are you thinking about your
childhood traumas where you're like
oh no that guy said something like
sydney sometimes wonders why like i take
30 40 minutes in the [ __ ] shower on
the [ __ ] toilet
and most of the time it's just me
thinking about different like that's my
most
creative zone it's like i mean where
it's like he's probably thinking about
other girls
meanwhile god kill you i destroyed you
in my head
most of my video ideas come when i'm
[ __ ] or in the shower i don't know
why
it's just it's just my special place
it's the zen it's it's
the same i feel like i'm just on my
phone and when i'm
shooting when i'm in the shower i just
yeah i'm also on my phone i have a
little
thing i watch youtube videos all of my
ideas come
right before i'm sure this is common but
it's right before i go to bed where i'm
just about to drift off to bed i'm just
i'm like
entering that rem state and then all of
a sudden i just wake up
activation i gotta write that down have
you ever had a like really funny dream a
really great dream that you
you wake up in the dream you're like
this will make an amazing video oh yeah
and then you make notes about it yeah
and then you read it in the morning and
you're like
what the [ __ ] was i saying oh my god
that's like
i have never experienced this what do
you mean half of my videos
come from that where i'm drifting off
into that rem sleep
and then i wake up i'm like this would
make a [ __ ] hilarious video and just
half eye and i write it down on my phone
and i go to sleep
next morning i go to open it up i'm just
like
what the [ __ ] this is a [ __ ] idea
i've never experienced that in my life
have you never i've texted in my sleep
and woke up and been like the [ __ ] today
but i've never had that no because like
i i've i've written some like
mad gibberish that i read on my notes on
the next day i'm like
i remember thinking when i when i wake
up from the stream this is like a slam
dunk idea this is like
a million dollar idea and then i wake up
and i was like um
evangelion indian service call i'm like
what the [ __ ] what what the [ __ ] is that
a real thing
is that a real idea i remember something
like that
and i'm just like wait what what was i
thinking
this man this man